enter to roll me to do with this paste
pan
r 4ds kon Derby is not blowing 2nd public opinion referee
Totoro, isn't it?
The starting point was that I wanted to make a movie like that.At
that bus stop, when I
was waiting for my father to come home
, a strange thing came next to me.A
fragment of that scene and a
little girl standing in the garden and looking at me.  With only those two images of a
semi-
transparent passing through in front of
me, I've had my sketchbook side for
more than 10 years.
There's no way the child
would go to pick her up like that, but she's standing in front of Totoro when Totoro picks her
up.The child has to be small
.  All of a
sudden, I found a solution, but with the
same specifications, it really flowed
and turned into sweets.
I started to add it,
so I wondered if it could be used in a movie,
and I had a lot of ideas about that, so I didn't come up with a plan,
but I think it's good that the plan didn't go through.
Well, I
've never seen anything about characters, so I can't
say anything about random things.
Hiding a woman, looking somewhere far away or not
looking at it, looking like writing that kind of name